what does your morning routine look like
at the moment I wake up round about what
time I'm waking up these days around 6
a.m and I have to be careful here
because whenever I've described my
routine in a little bit of detail people
always say I can't believe you don't go
to the bathroom so I want to be clear I
take care of my basic functions but when
I wake up I make a beeline for sunlight
the single best thing you can do for
your sleep your energy your mood your
wakefulness your metabolism is to get
natural light in your eyes early in the
day takes about 10 minutes or so this
sets in motion a huge number of
different neurobiological and hormonal
Cascades that are good for you reduces
stress late at night offsets cortisol a
million different things that are good
for you the quality studies on humans
that have looked at this say try and get
as much natural light as you can in the
morning hours especially the first three
hours after waking if you can work
outside great if you can get near a
window as opposed to just in a dark
conference room that's better but you
can get outside that would be fantastic